oui
on
[Musique]
l'hymne à la joie la cour du louvre
nous sommes le 7 mai 2010cette
souvenez-vous ya pas très longtemps
emmanuel macron vient d'être élu plus
jeune président dans une démocratie
moderne
emmanuel macron a déjoué bien des
pronostics
il n'a pas écouté la doxa et il a cru en
une chose très simple mais
incroyablement puissante en rien n'est
jamais écrit al avance emmanuel macron
est un homme mais des filles et des
femmes extraordinaires en crue aussi que
rien n'était jamais écrit al avance je
vais les inviter ce soir j'ai lu des
milliers de biographies donc je connais
les détails de la vie de milliers de
gens alors invitons les début du 20e
siècle
marie curie un prix nobel puis 2 pour
ses travaux sur la radioactivité
quarante années plus tard vous êtes dans
un bus bondé fait très chaud il ya une
femme noire qui est là elle a très mal
aux jambes et c'est pour ça qu'elle va a
dépassé les frontières de la convention
et refusait de céder sa place à un homme
blanc c'est rosa parks elle donnera le
coup d'envoi aux mouvements de
protestation en faveur de l'égalité
ethnique et aux grands discours de
martin luther king à abidjan
quelques années plus tard le monde est
ébahi devant neil amstrong qui marche
sur la lune mais c'est margaret hamilton
une femme dans son équipe qui a
travaillé sur le programme apollo
extraordinaire elle a traversé les
frontières de la matérialité
six ans plus tard précisément nous
sommes à l'assemblée nationale française
simone weil ministre de la santé dépasse
les frontières de la calomnie et de
l'agressivité pour faire voter la loi en
faveur de l'avortement et enfin il y en
a bien d'autres
mais je pourrais vous parler de mal à la
russa fall qui a risqué sa vie contre
les talibans en faveur de l'éducation
des filles et des femmes et qui a été
prix nobel de la paix à 17 ans en 2014
ces femmes elles sont connues et elles
ont la puissance mais l'anonymat ce
n'est pas une maladie contagieuse ans ce
n'est pas un soupirail
ça peut être un tremplin et tous les
jours des filles et des femmes connues
ou moins connues change le monde
traverse les frontières et 20 vont vers
leurs désirs
mais qu'est ce qui fait que certaines
d'entre elles sont comme ces enfants
virevoltant qui désirent leur rêve et
rêves leurs désirs et que d'autres n'y
parviennent pas quelles sont ses
frontières que l'on n'arrive pas à
surmonter parfois je voudrais vous
raconter trois histoires
la première c'est celle de la petite
lila elle a 10 ans et moi aussi
nous sommes près d'une cité dans la
banlieue nord de montpellier qui
s'appelle phobos phobos n'existe plus
mais à l'époque c'est un grand terrain
vague plein de poussière et de pauvreté
plein d'édifier savait qu'une immense
citerne que je revois là ce soir avec
lila est dans ma classe et un jour moi
j'habite les villages autour alors je
sais pas ce qui se passe ça phobos alors
je meurs d'envié je lui pose cette
question je lui dis mais qu'est ce qui
se passe à phobos qu'est ce qui se passe
derrière ses murs et ses frontières et
elle me répond d'un air très grave c'est
pas facile tous les jours
mais elle ajoute aussi mais qu'est ce
que ça change au fait et ça je m'en
souviendrai je m'en souviendrai toute ma
vie parce qu'à ce moment-là lilas elle
est prisonnière de la frontière sociale
elle est prisonnière de ce que sa vie de
ce à quoi sa vie ressemble mais là une
chance
foot le ballon rond en 98 la coupe du
monde arrive notamment à montpellier
avec zizou et ses copains et avant on
refait phobos elle change de maison elle
change d'état d'esprit
elle se met à lire des livres des romans
des poèmes lafore livre l'amour des
livres et ça va lui permettre de faire
cette chose incroyable ça va lui
permettre de daisy paix le réel des zips
et le réel c'est voir sa vie en 3d c'est
voir toutes les possibilités romanesque
qui nous sont offertes c voire par delà
les frontières du réel qui nous entoure
elle des zips le réel elle décide de
faire du théâtre elle deviendra
d'ailleurs aller aujourd'hui une grande
comédienne et à ce moment là je lui
demande comment elle a pris cette
décision et elle
dit d'un air très calme mais une fois
que j'ai des zips et le réel
je me suis rendu compte d'une chose
simple mais qui m'a guidé le pillant les
jamais la fin de rien mutatis mutandis
tout est toujours en mouvement
et comme rien n'est jamais écrit à
l'avancé on a le droit d'aller vers ce
mouvement on a le droit de traverser les
frontières
la deuxième histoire elle me brise
encore le coeur quand j'y pense c'est
celle de samira bellil samira bellil
c'est une éducatrice qui a été victime
de viol collectif en réunion pendant des
années je rappelle qu'une femme meurt
tous les trois jours sous les coups de
son compagnon en france pas simplement
au cours d'une d'un problème ponctuel
parce qu'on cherche à les assassiner
quand elles reprennent leur liberté je
rappelle que l'onu je suis engagé auprès
des nations unies pour l'égalité envers
les femmes et les hommes
l'onu dit qu'au cours de leur vie les
filles et les femmes pour 70% d'entre
elles subiront des violences et nous
sommes en 1999 dans l'amphithéâtre
bootmii à sciences po rue saint
guillaume
c'est un très grand amphithéâtre qui
fait à peu près cette taille et
auxquelles les étudiants sa tâche par ce
qu'il se passe beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de conférences diverses et
variées et je suis là ce jour là par
hasard
rendez vous compte par hasard alain dans
propos sur le bonheur nous dit que les
plus grandes choses de notre vie nous
arrive toujours par hasard ou pour des
raisons inattendue je suis là j'écoute
d'abord d'une oreille distraite parce
qu'il ya un débat sur les droits humains
et au début on est dans des données des
choses très docte et très savante et
puis d'un coup
samira bellil prend la parole et elle va
raconter son expérience mais elle va la
raconter avec ses mots à elle en pleine
amphithéâtre bootmii elle va employer
des mots châtié des mots sophistiquée
elle va raconter la violence elle va
raconter la violence comme si vous aviez
des poinot poignard qui venait sur votre
corps et à ce moment là et fait quelque
chose d'incroyable elle crée un malaise
tels que des gens quittent la pièce et
elle me chacun de ses pieds les deux
côtés de la frontière
elle nous dit en parlant de la violence
qu'elle a subie qu'est la capelle a été
capable de mettre un point qu'elle a
retrouvé sa liberté et en même temps ça
n'est qu'un point virgule
quelle ne nie pas la part d'ombré elle
ne nie pas ce qu'elle a vécu avant elle
sait que diviser sa vie ça revient se
diviser soi même samira bellil est morte
en 2004 des suites d'un cancer elle
était éducatrice
j'aimerais vraiment qu'elle ne soit pas
oublié
rien n'est jamais écrit à l'avancé et on
a tous nos points virgules
nos parts d'ombré nos parts de lumière
et tous tout sépare font partie de notre
récit personnel et intime
la troisième histoire c'est l'histoire
de marguerite c'est une amie de ma
famille vieille dame 1 qui est désormais
partie chatter avec le ciel elle était
extrêmement soleil provençal et je pense
à cette phrase de camus que je trouve
magnifique au milieu de l'hiver
j'apprenais enfin qu'il y avait en moins
était invincible
elle était comme ça c'était un était
invincible et c'est d'ailleurs en était
l'été de ses 20 ans qu'elle rencontra
grâce où elle habite à l'époque john
jones est le fils d'américains fortunés
qui vient passer l'été à grâce à l'odeur
des grillons le parfum déjà ceux du
jasmin et puis dans cet été incendiaires
ils vont s'aimer
ils vont s'aimer très fort et puis ils
ont 20 ans et à 20 ans et toujours pas
quoi faire de ses sentiments
parfois il nous embarrasse même si on
sait qu'ils sont là donc je ne repars de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique
et puis elle se met à l'attendre et au
début cette attente est insoutenable
parce que c'est une attente où elle est
dans le contrôle ans et puis petit à
petit elle va rentrer dans la maîtrise
elle va rentrer dans quelque chose de
plus doux et à ce moment là elle pense à
ces phrases en magnifique de rilke dans
lettres à un jeune poète ans vous êtes 6
9 et 6 jeunes devant les choses que je
voudrais vous inviter à être patient
devant ce qui n'est pas résolu dans
votre coeur et mes vos questions comme
des livres écrits dans une langue très
étrangère comme des portes fermées aimez
vos questions parce que si des réponses
vous été apportées à ce moment là vous
ne pourriez pas les vivants
or il s'agit de tous vivants et parce
que vous vivrez tous un jour
insensiblement vous entrerez dans la
réponse à ce moment là elle comprend et
elle me l'a dit qu'elle n'était pas
propriétaire de sa vie qu'elle était
dans une vie pour créer des moments
et puis espace à nouveau une chose
extraordinaire elle rencontre le kairos
alors le kairos c'est génial
le kairos figurez vous que c'est un
petit dieu et les dans la grèce antique
avec une touffe de cheveux et le kairos
ça n'est pas chronos ce n'est pas le
temps linéaire celui de votre montre
c'est celui qui vous ouvre une porte en
verre une autre perception de l'univers
c'est le temps de votre coeur c'est le
temps de votre ressenti
le kairos parfois ils passent et on le
voit pas parfois ils passent on le voit
et on n'arrive pas à le saisir pour
mille raisons d'ailleurs
et puis parfois ils passent et on le
saisit et vingt ans après la rencontre
avec john elle est devenu psychologue et
elle est invitée à boston pour faire une
conférence en elle m'a dit avoir
longuement hésité avant d'accepter elle
avait un livre à écrire elle avait des
choses à faire et d'autres vies auraient
pu être la sienne mais finit par
accepter cette proposition
elle est dans la salle de conférence
hélas au troisième rang précisément là
où vous êtes
en comptant de mattel dit elle voit qui
elle voit john john et psychologues et
il est un train et il se retrouve en est
à ce moment là ils se rendent compte que
le temps n'a pas de prise sur les
émotions véritable le temps c'est comme
une symphonie au fond la vie prend son
sens avec ce temps là parfois l'attend
nous est insupportable
mais on doit aimer cette vie en
confiance et ne pas la consommer avec
une impatience qui de toute façon nous
fera perdre le kairos il risque tout il
change de vie il ose vraiment parce
qu'on sait que l'on ose à ce que l'on
est prêt à perdre
le kairos le tapis volant formidable des
zips et le réel considérer les points
virgules en écouter le kairos sachez
qu'il existe
vous avez maintenant quelques
ingrédients pour ne pas vous laisser
écrire votre histoire pour l'écrire vous
même et on va essayer de le faire tout
de suite vous allez fermer les yeux
d'abord ou des zips et le réel à votre
rythme en vous voyez votre vie en 3d en
4d en 5 des andes idée vous voyez toutes
les possibilités qui peuvent s'offrir à
vous tous les chemins que vous voulez
visualiser puis vous intégrer vos points
virgules
vous avez eu vos tourments vous avez eu
leur part d'ombré et vous avez retrouvé
votre liberté vous avez mis des points
et puis des virgules ans la virgule
c'est ce qui vous permet de ne pas
oublier de ne pas retranché et de vous
dire que dans votre récit il ya de
l'ombre il ya de la lumière et enfin
penser très fort à ce que vous voudriez
avoir de plus cher et que vous n'avez
pas encore pensé à votre kairos ce n'est
pas grave si ce n'est pas un petit dieu
et les avec une touffe de cheveux
imaginer le comme vous le souhaitez sous
la forme que vous souhaitez faites lui
confiance qu'en dire c'est faire il
viendra
vous pouvez maintenant ré ouvrir les
yeux et vous avez un petit bout de votre
nouvelle histoire frontières mentales
frontières sociales frontières
culturelles frontière psychologique
je n'oublie pas néanmoins ce soir qu à
alep et dans d'autres villes du monde
il ya des gens qui sont obligés de
traverser les frontières pour sauver
leur peau pour sauver la peau leur
famille ça je ne l'oublierai pas il ya
des frontières qu'on n'arrive pas à
traverser quel que soit notre volonté
mais il ya aussi des frontières comme
ces femmes ans que j'ai invité ce soir
avec nous que l'on peut traverser que
l'on doit traverser
parce qu'elle nous amène vers nos vrais
rêves et ça me rappelle ce magnifique
poèmes de lamartine qui était sur une
carte que mes parents adoraient m'avait
acheté une carte postale que j'ai perdus
dans un train mais j'ai gardé lamartine
le livre de la vie et le livre
suprêmement qu'on ne peut ni fermer ni
rouvrira son choix le passage attachant
ne s'y lie pas deux fois
mais le feuillet fatale si tourner de
lui même on voudrait revenir à la page
où l'on aime
mais la page où l'on meurt et déjà sous
nos doigts la vie va vite
alors ce soir jeudi à toutes les filles
de france et de navarre quelques peuvent
courir vers leur vraie vie et traverser
leurs frontières mais à vous aussi
messieurs
parce que c'est ensemble que nous
construirons un monde meilleur et ça
nous pouvons écrire à l'avance
oui
[Musique]